alain juppé bonsoir vous et réprimés
depuis la fin de l'année dernière merci
d'avoir réservé fonde ses explications
alors on vient de le voir les plans de
relance se suivent et se ressemblent
parfois le dernier date de fin décembre
la plupart des indicateurs sont au rouge
notamment sommet de dire d'un bon dans
l'instant est ce qu'il n'aurait pas
fallu beaucoup plus d'audace comme
disait l'autre
beaucoup d'indicateurs sont au vert par
le chômage nous y reviendrons mais
beaucoup sont au vert quand vous dites
que la plupart sont au rouge c'est la
croissance l'inflation est tout à fait
aux verts le commerce extérieur est tout
à fait tôt vers l'investissement se
porte plutôt bien et ainsi de suite
je vois simplement recadrer un peu les
choses par rapport à ce que nous avons
fait depuis maintenant huit mois
puisqu'il y a huit mois que j'ai pris
mes fonctions premières parties de cette
période
disons le deuxième semestre de 1995 a
été une période de consolidation
il a fallu faire des choses difficiles
impopulaire mais qu'il fallait bien
faire je voudrais deux exemples la
première d'abord ça a été d'arrêter la
dérive des finances publiques qui
existait depuis plusieurs années et pour
cela il a fallu augmenter les impôts ce
qui n'est jamais bien reçu par l'opinion
publique bien sûr mais s'est créé et
nous avons atteint nos objectifs on le
verra d'ailleurs bientôt le budget 95 a
été exécuté comme prévu autre exemple de
ce qu'il fallait faire
qui n'était pas facile qui n'était pas
populaire mais qui était inévitable la
reprise des essais jacques chirac a eu
le courage de le faire ces essais
avaient été interrompue prématurément et
ne nous permettaient pas d'assurer
l'avenir car nous avons assuré l'avenir
est maintenant c'est derrière nous si
bien que 96 97 pourront être des années
de dialogue social et des années de
relance pour la france c'est de ça qu'il
s'agit maintenant on vous dit les plans
se succèdent et ne se ressemblent pas où
se ressemblent c'est pas tout à fait
exact qu'est ce qu'on a fait depuis
plusieurs mois on a d'abord essayé
d'alléger les charges sociales
et ça a marché avec le contrat
initiative emploi ensuite j'ai fait un
plan pme pmi fin novembre il n'est pas
en fermant il n'est pas encore en
application
puisqu'il faut voter les textes
nécessaires au mois de mars fin décembre
nous avons pris des mesures pour libérer
l'épargné qui était bloqué par exemple
les réserves de participation des
salariés
et comme il ya eu des difficultés
depuis lors nous avons aujourd'hui en
concertation avec dalmat il franchit une
nouvelle étape dont nous avons parlé je
pense maintenant plus en détail voilà la
cohérence voilà la logique avec un
objectif bien clair pour ces deux années
96 97 dialogue social relance de la
france avec celle d'il ya un problème
c'est un problème de confiance envers
venir à propos du chômage pourquoi à
votre avis les français n'ont pas encore
confiance ou non pas confiance c'est
vrai que la confiance a été mise à mal
pendant les derniers mois de 1995 c'est
difficile d'analyser parce que c'est
très subtil j'y verrai pour ma part
plusieurs raisons d'abord il ya eu une
augmentation des impôts j'ai dit
pourquoi il fallait remettre de l'ordre
dans nos finances et ça n'est jamais
bien reçu c'est fait et vous le savez
j'ai donné des instructions à bobigny et
les ministres je ne veux plus de
réformes qui se traduisent par de
nouvelles augmentations d'impôts et nous
avons écrit hier nous avons pour
objectif le président de la république
l'a dit 97 98 d'abord c'est la baisse
des impôts comme les allemands ont dit
qu'ils allaient le faire
le deuxième élément qui explique cette
mise à mal de la confiance dont vous
parliez c'est peut-être les incertitudes
politiques liées aussi aux mouvements
sociaux bien aussi je crois que le
paysage est clarifiée nous avons devant
nous deux ans le président de la
république a fixé le cap et la majorité
soutient l'action gouvernementale elle
est certes diverses
j'ai parfois un peu turbulente c'est
normal mais elle est loyal et chaque
fois que j'ai besoin d'elle elle me
soutient
et puis enfin pour établir la confiance
il faut avoir le cap
le but dans les deux ans qui viennent je
pense qu'on en pense quand on en parlera
à propos de l'europe
ce but il est clairement fixé
aujourd'hui et nous devons être en 1998
dans le peloton de tête de l'europe pour
le bien-être des français et pour la
soule à l'indépendance de la france
alors on disait tout à l'heure l'un des
indicateurs qui est rouge nettement
c'est le chômage on a eu vous avez
annoncé aujourd'hui avec un petit peu
quelques heures d'avancé
le chiffre 12 avons sur deux mois
puisqu'il n'y a pas eu de relevés
statistiques en novembre en raison des
grèves une hausse de 57 milles du nombre
d'inscrits à l'anpe les deux derniers
mois
sur donc sur deux mois surtout les
jeunes etc ce qui fait que la cour on le
voit là sur l'écran repasse le cap
fatidique des 3 millions de chômeurs on
revient en arrière à mars 95 grâce aux
commentaires
mais ces chiffres ne sont pas bons sur
l'ensemble de l'année 1995 le chômage a
diminué 55000 à peu près ce qu'est la
plus forte diminution depuis 1989
sur les 12 mois il est vrai que les deux
ou trois derniers mois n'ont pas été
bons il faut réagir et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous proposons ces mesures
de relance de l'emploi
il faut bien analyser les choses aussi
je les vis tout à l'heure sur le chômage
de longue durée
nous avons remporté des succès le
contrat initiative emploi a permis de
remettre dans le cycle du travail
pratiquement 150 mille personnes et
c'est une réussite
en revanche nous sommes mauvais je le
dis et c'est grave parce que c'est
vraiment l'exception française au
mauvais sens du terme nous sommes
mauvais pour les jeunes il faut donc
faire un effort national pour
l'insertion des jeunes
ce doit être la priorité absolue de ces
années 80 c'est un autre niveau
vous savez un objectif de 150 millions
et sa création d'emplois pour des 150
millions de 80 saisons tiendra
l'objectif il faut le tenir vous savez
que nous l'avons fixé pas tout seul nous
n'avons fixé avec les partenaires
sociaux c'est le 21 décembre dernier
lorsque j'ai rencontré les organisations
professionnelles et syndicales
nous avons convenu ensemble que ce
devait être un objectif de mobilisation
nationale on est en train d'y travailler
et j'ai fixé un rendez-vous dans le
milieu de l'année 1996 précisément aux
partenaires sociaux pour qu'on puisse
faire le point des mesures qui ont été
prises
vous avez le sentiment d'avoir l'appui
du patronat en l'occurrence au serait le
patronat ses vastes d'abord c'est varié
il ya des milliers peut-être des
millions de chefs d'entreprise il ya
ceux qui parlent en leur nom et qui
n'explique pas toujours le sentiment de
la base j'ai la conviction que beaucoup
de chefs de pme veulent se développer
aujourd'hui et sont conscients qu'ils
ont un devoir d'insertion des jeunes
c'est là-dessus qu'il faut gagner la
bataille c'est là dessus qu'on rétablira
finalement la confiance parce que c'est
parce que nous avons 25 % de jeunes de
moins de 25 ans en dehors de la vie de
travail que cette confiance ne revient
pas c'est ça le facteur essentiel sur
lequel je veux vraiment m'engager avec
toutes les forces de la nation lors vous
est pris une décision qui va faire
couler beaucoup beaucoup d'encre et de
salive l'abaissement du taux d'intérêt
du livret a
les réactions sont plutôt négatives même
largement négative en gros on dénonce la
case de l' épargne populaire alors en
quelques mots pourquoi avoir pris cette
décision sachant que vous touchez un
tabou elle était réclamée depuis bien
longtemps dans l'état de milieu des
journaux économiques tous ceux qui
regardent un peu comment évoluent les
choses et je ne suis pas sûr que les
réactions soient aussi négative que vous
vouliez bien le dire certes oui le
syndicat pas tous nous allons
l'expliquer vous avez du planeur dit que
c'était un bas de laine que des livrets
d'épargné le livret a
ce n'est pas exact qui cet argent parce
que vous avez vous avez utilisé la
formule cet argent il n'est pas mis dans
un bas de laine et qu'elle n'est pas
précisément il sert à quelque chose
il sert à prêter de l'argent aux
organismes hlm qui construisent des
logements sociaux pour les français qui
en ont besoin
c'est à ça que sert l'argent du livret a
or que se passe-t-il à l'heure actuelle
ces organismes de hlm sont dans une
mauvaise posture
parce que l'argent que leur prêtent est
trop cher pour qu'ils puissent lancer de
nouveaux programmes de logement social
ou entretenir les logements dont ils
sont déjà pris propriétaire or qu'est ce
que nous avons voulu faire nous avons
voulu donner un formidable ballon
d'oxygène aux organismes hlm en baissant
le taux des prêts qu'il avait fait et
pour cela bien entendu il fallait
ajuster la rémunération du livret a
voilà la raison d'être de cette mesure
j'ajoute qu'à l'heure actuelle
l'inflation en france est de 2,1 pour
cent que les taux ont baissé partout
vous disiez tout à l'heure que les
banques ont baissé de 0 5% mais quand on
fait la somme des baisses successives
depuis le mois d'octobre
elles ont baissé en réalité 2 1
1 % et les taux d'intérêt à court terme
en france était une grande réussite du
gouvernement depuis mai 1995
on essaie de 3 3% il fallait accompagner
ce mouvement
j'ajoute tout de suite que j'ai veillé à
ce que l'épargné des français les moins
favorisés ne subissent pas de
pénalisation et quand vous voyez que le
premier livre et populaire dont nous
avons parlé tout à l'heure est à 4 75%
on ne peut pas laisser dire que l'
épargne populaire est pénalisé ce n'est
pas exact avec ce nouveau livre et 40
mille francs de plafond qui va concerner
18 millions de français
pratiquement les deux tiers des français
imposable les trois quarts de l'ensemble
des français
l'épargné des plus défavorisés et
protégé est rémunéré à un niveau qui est
un des plus élevés de tous les
placements qu'on trouve aujourd'hui lors
des mois vous avez vu qu'il avait
entendu quelques épargnants inquiétez
pas très content et 10 à ces petits
épargnants qui trinquera qu'est ce que
vous dites aux petits épargnants
ce soir on vous pique pas d'argent et de
nos plus petits il ya effectivement le
let qui vous permet d'avoir un bon taux
de rémunération dont il rentre en selle
dès tous ceux qui en moins de quarante
mille francs dans un livret a est là
aussi il faut ramener les choses c'est
juste proportion parce que on est en
train d' d'émouvoir la population
française en disant mais les gens qui
ont cent mille francs sur un livret de
caisse d'epargne n'auront plus quatre et
demi mais trois demi pour cent
quatre-vingt pour cent quatre-vingts
pour cent des titulaires de livrer des
personnes qui ont un livret a ont moins
de 40 mille francs sur la rive rien et
celle là non seulement ne sont pas
pénalisés mais si elle j'ouvre a livré
un premier livre et populaire elles
auront même 4 75 au lieu de 4 50
alors évidemment les 20% qui ont
beaucoup plus cent mille francs parfois
plusieurs fois cent mille francs est ce
qu'on peut avoir plusieurs livres et
dans une même famille cela est bien y
contribueront à l'effort de solidarité
nationale en permettant aux offices hlm
d'avoir une ressource meilleur marché et
de construire de logements neufs
je crois que cette réforme est juste et
que là encore vous avez parlé d'un tabou
il faut quand même évolué avec son temps
les taux d'intérêts aujourd'hui sont
historiquement bas on n'a pas vu ça
depuis 23 ans
on ne peut pas continuer à asphyxier la
construction sociale en maintenant des
prêts aux hlm aussi élevés qu'ils le
sont depuis des années alors le coup de
pouce au crédit
la consommation ça c'est un petit coup
de pouce pour les pour les classes
moyennes pour qu'effectivement il
emprunte il s'équipe oui on nous dit
aujourd'hui que les français sont
réticents devant la consommation on a
fait par exemple une mesure pour les
automobiles avec une prime dite à la
casse qui n'a pas très bien fonctionné
pourquoi parce que le crédit à la
consommation est très cher trop cher et
le ministre de l'économie des finances
et de raison de dire aux banques qu'il
fallait le baisser alors pour contribuer
à cette baisse de manière un peu
transitoire jusqu'à la fin de l'année
nous avons fait une déduction fiscale
qui revient à baisser en réalité le coût
de ce crédit à la consommation je crois
que le moment est maintenant venu pour
ceux qui attendaient avant d'investir ou
avant de consommer que les taux soient
bas de le faire j'ajoute qu'il ya
également les peut-être le signalez vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure une mesure
favorable à l'investissement des
entreprises
là aussi pour profiter de ces taux
d'intérêt historiquement bas
moi j'ai une petite question sur la
consommation et on s'est demandé hier
pourquoi supprimer l'allocation 900
francs versés aux femmes enceintes
cinquième mois jusqu'aux trois mois
après la naissance
est ce que c est par là aussi un petit
moyen de consommer un peu plus et
acheter un équipement à auxerre les deux
chabot je sais que c'est le souci
permanent de france 2 quand on donne des
informations il faut les données avec
précision on n'a pas aimé c'est très
important ça change tout ça change
vous venez de maintenant on peut dire
tout soyez précise vous de venir on
supprime cette allocation
on la supprime que pour les ménages qui
n'ont pas n'ont pas de dix mille francs
mais seize mille francs par mois et pour
les premiers mois c'était déjà le cas à
partir du 3ème mois après la grossesse
eh bien nous unissions cette mesure il
ajoute je voudrais poser une question de
fond parce qu'au delà de ces mesures
d'actualité il faut bien quand même que
la société française réfléchissent sur
des questions de fond est ce qu'il est
normal d'aider exactement les familles
de la même manière quel que soit leur
niveau de revenu est ce qu'une famille
qui a trente mille francs doit être
aidée de la même manière qu'une famille
qu'à 8000 francs admettez que cette
question se pose je suis pas dire le
seul à la pause et les hommes de gauche
la pose aussi et bien c'est une question
que je veux mettre à l'ordre du jour de
la grande rencontre sur la politique
familiale
en 2000 que j'ai envisagé de réunir au
mois de mars prochain parce que cette
question elle se pose pour l'ensemble de
nos allocations familiales loyer que
derrière il ya aussi un souci de
solidarité et de plus grande justice
dans l'utilisation de l'argent public on
va parler un petit peu de ce qui se
passe en allemagne aujourd'hui le
gouvernement un prix globalement a
également